harry styles is making pride dreams come
true helping one fan come out during his
concert at wembley stadium stadium in
london over the weekend i love this so
much harry spotted a sign in the crowd
that he couldn't ignore which read from
uno to wembley help me come out and he
took a couple moments to appreciate his
fans big moment congratulating him in a
being a free man
[Applause]
so you would like
the people of wembley to bring
[Applause]
when this flag
goes above my head
you are officially out
okay
when this sign goes over the head you're
officially gay my boy
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no it's still straight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i love harry styles so much harry styles
is
such an icon yes
everything he does again jennifer lopez
to harry styles like both of them are
just making so many differences and
speaking truth and helping people
understand like this was such a great
moment in celebration of someone that
was sober and they had a sign up right
and he took the time to read the sign
and make the difference and it's
enjoying it's just pride month and i
think harry would do this during any
month but harry is
just i think somebody who really is when
we talk about people making a difference
yeah harry can we also talk about how
cute he is he is so freaking cute
like the cutest let's be real he kind of
looks like in that video look at him
just awesome he does remind me a bit on
stage when he was with that flag i'm
like a young elton john oh
and i think harry is gonna move along in
his career
and be an icon like elton john
he's amazing i love his style so much ah
i do get a hairy style so i was just
laughing i'm such a nerd all right
there he is again with the sign oh
such a moment look at that yeah special
very special